well thinking back to when you were 12
or when you first became a grand
mastermind is were you able to think
like that after
maybe losing uh games against top
players were you able to look at okay i
learned this
i did good in this position okay that
was good or were you angry after losses
like that
well first of all i wasn't quite as good
as mishra is now when i was
i was 12. um
but i would say that although i would
get
upset after losses i wasn't somebody who
was too used to winning
so i generally sought out stronger
opposition
and tried to learn from from those games
all right then obviously tomorrow
uh semi-finals coming up for you in the
world cup so how is this commentating
here helping you in your preparations or
working
uh with your preparations for tomorrow
i think it's pretty neutral as long as i
can get
get a decent decent meal after it aha
and uh well we do know young christophe
duda is coming up for you in the
semi-finals tomorrow first of all how
happy are you with uh how you've been
playing so far in the world cup
i think it's been pretty uh pretty good
um there was i think only one
one moment where i was uh close to um
to being out which was against uh
watashi in the second
second rapid sorry the second classical
game there were some
some some difficult moments there but i
think against isipanko
although it was a very tough match i was
never
never close to to actually losing it so
yeah it's it's been it's been good i've
gotten great practice and
hope to um hope to play a couple more
good matches
and um yeah having this up close view in
sochi at the world cup of all of these
youngsters breaking through players like
esapenko
some of the uzbek and indian players
who's impressed you the most over there
no i think yes pencil is very very um
impressive um looking at his games
preparing i was um
yeah i was almost stunned at his ability
to
just outplay people in almost purely
positional positional way with um
um with with pressure so i think he has
potential to be one of the very very
best players in the
in the world uh apart from that uh
yeah i think as as for with a lot of
people cinderella
was was uh was impressive and i expect
him to make
a huge huge jump in the in the rankings
and well obviously magnus four months
before the world championship match how
important has it been for you to get a
feel for the pieces again and place them
over the board
no it's been great uh i could feel at
the start that i was a bit out of
practice but now i feel
i feel good and um it's certainly
helping
yeah all right well magnus we thank you
so much for
uh your commentary on that previous game
and uh good luck
uh in the semi-finals against judah
tomorrow
thank you so much